welcome to video playing G roam here
with black ok g3 yeah that's a quite
interesting sideline that I often
recommend to people looking for an
offbeat solution to Sicilian I'm trying
I'm trying some flexible set up here
with black I really don't know what's
good to be honest then this looks I
Scott Queenie forechecker yet Queen a4
check okay oh I guess he still has that
but no wow yeah c4 is a typical idea was
just entirely mistimed okay maybe just
try to keep that pawn what the weird
would we adjourn um create sequence iam
be 40 50 ok let's a taxi form I mean I'm
better developed here at it's nice wow
that feels a bit passive really ok I
have to check now wonder if a five is
actually a movie 595 let's do it not so
easy to decide upon button I thought
that I should have a pretty good
pressure here honest on this position
this pin
maybe even night you for as an idea a
threatened rope tonight xp3 so I
understand them okay I don't have any
tactic here may be roped III but unsure
and a bit unsure okay so and you have a
for at least but not sure that this is
so helpful I mean maybe just here 92 f5
and e4 that's really awkward and I can
take see 3 yeah this is this looks good
this looks good on the immediate efore
yet 95 I'm not sure yet but the saw the
salt so nice where to go to d 192 not
probably background probably back night
see two f5s nice i always have some
pressure that's four for luke 22 may be
lucrative one night see tool ok let's go
ahead five then ok
check okay Izzy five right or not
interesting question I guess it is that
space is very useful to have
my scored four points against two but
the points are not going anywhere while
my forgan to look rather dangerous
the night's feel a little bit cramped
there they don't have really have much
to do
man that's very uncomfortable position
yeah thats it's one of the few ideas
that read that he had maybe age 6 ask
him where are you going to go yam and he
iruku vade or Luke f8 I guess keep this
keep this intact to the structure next
step is spring the King up an idea for
check but that's just a check really
check bishops you five maybe I'm Bishop
c5 check why not notifies the self pin I
just move the king i take the night next
can you to walk you to check i think yes
to go back yeah exactly and now yeah
probably just that side step
stepping out of that file here possibly
has room to five and want to go E 4 95
that would be nice but okay that gives
him f4 I have to be a bit cautious
they're probably F for King at five yeah
that's better
so look with seven coming no it's not
going there I have 95 here maybe I'll
just bring the king of is there any
particular problem 94 kini for not
really this I don't see it
okay time morning may be here right Oh
94 might be an idea than 94
check check check and stupid I have to
cover that why would I way am I going
there I was so was entirely wrong oh
come on come on don't tell me I'm
spoiling this it was just as it was
completely in my pocket disposition
check but I really screwed it up amazing
yeah really amazing check n kim was
entirely with haley entirely I know is
tricking me with mouse tricks here
unbelievable it's tough gain drawn yeah
and yeah I mean I probably would have
resigned in yeah but stuff like rook f6
is just I mean I absolutely have to be a
long time then or draw on time yeah if
people go for this kind of stuff so yeah
I mean I can just take it in Windham and
and of course here it is just completely
over what did I do wrong I mean okay
maybe I can actually prevent before
entirely maybe that is the point should
be six daz for maybe up we're so should
should be a very easy win yeah that was
strong that was a strong move all of a
sudden yeah this is stronger keeping an
eye there and he and then I'm invading
yeah it still requires some precision of
quite clearly
having a draw is completely blocked from
a great position like that even that
should be good for black check the two
pawns are pretty strong and Knight b6
was good here but we didn't exactly have
much time and I made many this wasn't
this was entirely stupid of course I
have to keep that covered I just have to
take here and then then get ya some are
trying to get this pawn going not quite
sure how exactly but what is his move I
mean he doesn't really have many useful
moves on here and then maybe step up
it's not so easy to move that very
strange it looks like the two passes
should do the trick but it's not that
easy yeah really shouldn't shouldn't
have gone that far I mean this is this
is just a winning position here for
black not more and not less the two
pawns bishop t6 is really strong young
and he goes before now I can just ignore
the whole procedure Butchie forehead
it's also nice looking at this yeah a
little bit more precision that you
probably will not recover from that okay
well thanks for watching